simbólica victoria para armenia en el
conflicto con azerbaiyán con un solo
voto en contra y 30 abstenciones el
senado francés adoptó este martes una
resolución que invita al gobierno de
macrón a reconocer la república de
nagorno karabaj el senado aboga por
utilizar este reconocimiento como
instrumento las negociaciones por una
paz duradera en la región senadores de
los cinco grupos parlamentarios que
propusieron esta resolución se han
congratulado en redes sociales por la
decisión muy orgulloso de la votación
del senado que pide al gobierno por 305
votos de 306 que reconozca la república
de nagorno karabaj en 2019 macrón ya
anunció que el 24 de abril sería
dedicado a la conmemoración del
genocidio armenio
no en vano en francia se encuentra
actualmente la tercera comunidad armenia
más grande del mundo una resolución que
no es vinculante ha sido acogida con
júbilo por parte del gobierno de ereván
extiendo mi profunda gratitud a france y
al pueblo francés por la resolución del
senado sobre el reconocimiento de la
república de artsaj francia reafirma su
apego a los valores universales así como
al respeto de los principios
fundamentales del derecho internacional
sin embargo se ha puesto en duda la
objetividad de francia como presidente
del grupo de minsk que supervisa el alto
al fuego la zona
armenia y azerbaiyán acordaron el pasado
10 de noviembre un cese al fuego total
en la región después de más de un mes de
conflicto hasta entonces la guerra se
había cobrado miles de víctimas en ambos
bandos y más de 75.000 desplazados